qué es una empresa y ustedes tal vez
trabajan en una empresa son gerente en
una empresa o dueños o asesoran a una o
al menos sin dudas compran cosas de una
empresa se han hecho alguna vez esta
pregunta qué es una empresa
esta aparentemente obvia y simple
pregunta cambió mi visión sobre los
negocios me dio esperanza para la
economía mejor y más sustentable
ustedes yo estaba sentado en una
conferencia y le expliqué el pregunto
qué es una empresa
instintivamente lo primero que salió de
la boca de las personas fueron
siguientes una empresa es un grupo de
personas que trabajan juntas por un
propósito por una misión
y escuché sin decir nada
por supuesto que yo sabía lo que era en
empresa
aprendí que una empresa es una entidad
que ejerce una actividad comercial con
el propósito de generar y distribuir las
ganancias entre los socios
esta definición de empresa marcó toda mi
experiencia como abogada corporativa y
lamentablemente marcó mi opinión sobre
los negocios en las empresas de una
forma muy negativa
y esto es alice en compra y ventas de
sociedades en este campo te acostumbras
a tratar las empresas como si fueran
cosas novieta adquirible proyecto de
especulación de los accionistas para
aumentar sus tres tornos
no es nada de extrañarse porque en
términos legales una empresa es una cosa
no hay mucha diferencia entre ser dueño
de una empresa o ser dueño de un pan que
se puede cortar en pedazos se puede
comer se puede vender
lo que pasó es que un día mi empresa fue
vendida la empresa en la cual trabajaba
como asesora legal yo trabajé en esta
adquisición y día mi nombre el nombre de
mis compañeros todo que habíamos
trabajado logrado creado con un abyecto
de adquisición con un precio a su lado
trabajar en la adquisición de mi empresa
fue como una calidad en la cara muy
fuerte y 3er
pero me despertó
empecé a observar las implicancias de
eso el trabajo que yo estaba haciendo
del sistema dentro de un año de la
adquisición de mi empresa todos los
ejecutivos y la mayoría de los empleados
yo incluida se fueron
porque la mitigación disminuyó
radicalmente no nos sentíamos más
responsables por esa empresa porque al
final ya no era nuestra empresa era la
compañía de los accionistas y quiénes
eran estos accionistas
eran fondos administrados por gente que
ni siquiera conocíamos el mercado de las
acciones dueños ausentes y sólo se
preocupaban por los números por el valor
de las acciones y estaban listo para
vendernos de nuevo al mejor postor
pero bueno el gerente general tenía el
deber legal de servir a los intereses de
los accionistas docentes
entonces tenemos empleados desconectados
accionistas docentes y un gerente que
tiene que servir a los intereses de los
accionistas ausentes
yo aprendí
el problema no era esta empresa
especifica el problema era el sistema
entero que funciona así
y eso me pareció aterrador
tratar a las empresas como si fueran una
cosa que un vacío una falta de
responsabilidad con respecto a su misión
puesto que la empresa tiene que
enfocarse en los retornos económicos de
corto plazo
eso no solamente es triste para los
empleados sino que también pone en
riesgo el desarrollo de la empresa misma
en el largo plazo
esa falta de responsabilidad en el
corazón de las empresas el motor de
nuestra economía
puede poner y ya ha puesto a nuestro
planeta de riesgo
y eso me pareció aún más aterrador ver y
darme cuenta de todo eso
fue doloroso renunciar a mi trabajo
viaje un rato y decidí de hacer algo
significativo si es necesario dejar de
abandonar al derecho corporativo a
empezar una nueva carrera desde cero
pero aquella conferencia que le cuenta
va al inicio me dio esperanza para una
forma mejor de hacer negocios entonces
en vez de arrancarme del sistema
decidí de ser parte del cambio ser parte
de la solución
experta por un lado la ley define a las
empresas con una cosa de propiedad de
las accionistas para extraer las
ganancias y esa definición enfermedad
todo el sistema económico pero por otro
lado hay mucha gente que tiene una
concepción muy diferente de lo que es
una empresa todo lo que debería ser un
grupo de personas trabajando juntas por
un propósito por una misión
entonces
podemos traducir esta definición
sustantivamente diferente en términos
legales
así que podemos si es que actuar más en
el mismísimo corazón de las empresas la
propiedad
donde las reglas de gobernanza son
definidas donde las limitaciones y las
posibilidades de lo que los dueños
pueden hacer son fijadas donde la regla
transferencia de la propiedad son
declaradas
juguemos un poco con esas reglas
imaginemos
qué pasaría si la empresa tuviese padres
y se cuidan de ella algo parecido como
un negocio familiar pero a diferencia de
un negocio familiar el control los
derechos de votos sobre la empresa pasan
de una generación de padres a la
siguiente pasado en sus conexión con las
empresas en sus habilidades no basados
en las usan guineos o en el dinero la
empresa nunca se puede enter o heredar
como si fuese una cosa
y qué pasaría
si el propósito de esa empresa de esta
familia no fuera la extracción de la
ganancia por el lucro de los accionistas
para servir a la misión de la empresa a
sus clientes a la sociedad entera
prácticamente la mayoría de las
ganancias son reinvertidas en la misión
de la empresa o tonadas y ya son el
combustible para perseguir a la misión
de la empresa que es encontrar
soluciones lucrativas
para solucionar las necesidades de la
sociedad del planeta eso es
no pasaría
ya me lo imagino
y veo un grupo de gente motivada
trabajando en conjunto por un propósito
de una familia de valores y de misión de
una empresa que se pertenece a sí mismo
un organismo social
cómo se sentiría uno en frente de esta
empresa uno podría confiar más uno
podría pensar que si existen las
condiciones para que esta empresa actúe
responsablemente
bueno existirá de esta empresa o sólo en
nuestros sueños
estas empresas son reales se llaman
empresas de propiedad responsable porque
han incorporado en su adn los dos
principios que acabo de describir que
hacen que la propiedad sea entendida con
responsabilidad el principio de la
autodeterminación por el cual timón de
la empresa se queda con personas
conectadas con la misión de la empresa
pero personas hábiles para tomar las
decisiones y el propósito del lucro
sirviendo al propio al propósito el
principio del lucro sirviendo al
propósito
la propiedad responsable este concepto
en inglés stuart 17 se basa en muchos
ejemplos de empresarios que se
preguntaron qué es una empresa y
desafiaron el concepto tradicional de
propiedad
el primero en hacer eso fue caballero y
se llama en esta p él es el cofundador
de saiz que es una empresa bien exitosa
es el líder mundial en óptica
microscopios
bueno cuando carl zeiss murió el otro
fundador establece quedó con la
responsabilidad de decidir qué hacer con
esta empresa
y se preguntó qué es esta empresa de
quién eres a quién sirve
escribió la ley me da el derecho
absoluto de hacer lo que quiera con esa
empresa
pero esto no se siente correcto él se
dio cuenta que la definición del ilegal
de empresa no encajaba con su concepto
de lo que era una empresa todos los
logros de la empresa 6 eran el resultado
del trabajo de todos los empleados y de
generaciones de científicos e ingenieros
y por eso pertenece la empresa pertenece
a ellos también ya la sociedad entera la
cual servía
entonces el que ya era un inventor se
inventó una estructura de propiedad
nueva él donó su empresa a una fundación
y diseñó un sistema de gobernancia bien
elaborado gracias al cual la empresa 6
se queda independiente alineada con su
misión y exitosas en 130 años
la ganancia que ha generado esta empresa
han permitido grandes innovaciones
tecnológicas y han apoyado muchos
proyectos e investigaciones en las
universidades y también han apoyado a la
comunidad de llena la ciudad de saiz
bueno consideramos a esta p el inventor
de la propiedad responsable pero la
buena noticia es que hay muchos otros
ejemplos de empresarios que se
cuestionaron el concepto tradicional de
empresa
y encontraron formas jurídicas que
reflejan los dos principios de la
propiedad responsable de la
autodeterminación electrónica
bueno hay muchos ejemplos hay muchos
otros ejemplos de empresas que
cuestionaron el concepto de propiedad
tenemos el gigante industrial vos la
empresa de juguetes en playmobil el
buscador
mozilla y escocia tenemos la banca ética
triodos bank y muchos otros el 60% del
mercado de gran marca es de propiedad
responsable lo que hicieron estas
empresas es reinventar repensar el
concepto de propiedad corporativa y ha
funcionado muy bien hay estudios de la
universidad de copenhague de la
universidad de yale que han demostrado
que estas empresas son muchas más
innovadoras de las empresas
tradicionales que los empleados son
intrínsecamente motivados porque ya
saben que están trabajando por un
propósito y entonces se quedan más
tiempo en la empresa y también ganan
salarios más altos los consumidores
confían más en estas empresas
esa es empresa también tienen son muy
estables y tiene una vida mucho más
larga de las empresas tradicionales
entonces la propiedad responsable que
desafía las reglas tradicionales de
transmisión del control el dinero la
sangre que cambia el concepto
tradicional de empresa de la era
capitalista de verdad funciona
incorporando en esa los dos principios
de la propiedad responsable
autodeterminación y lucro sirviendo en
propósito se permite a las empresas no
solamente de ser rentables
económicamente rentables pero también de
quedarse independientes y alineada con
la misión general a largo plazo les
permite de actuar responsablemente a
beneficio de las personas entonces ahora
concluyendo se acuerdan de esta
conferencia de la cual estaba hablando
la que me dio esperanza para una
economía mejor bueno esta conferencia
fue organizada por la fundación por post
en la cual y ahora trabajo finalmente
puede usar mis herramientas de abogada
corporativa para algo que me hace
sentido para que más y más empresas de
cualquier países de cualquier tamaño
puedan ser de propiedad responsable
puedan de verdad ser un grupo de
personas que trabajan juntas por una
misión
hemos soñado
con empresas guiadas por padres y
enfocadas en el propósito y hemos
descubierto que estos derechos ya
existen
ahora imaginemos una economía que fue
con todo el progreso que ya ha logrado
puede ser sanada y mejorada por estas
empresas
la economía que puede usar su grande
poder grande fuerza a beneficio de las
personas a beneficio de la sociedad a
beneficio de ésta en una economía que
pueda actuar responsablemente para las
generaciones de hoy y del futuro un día
en el futuro cercano nos despertemos y
esa economía ya existe
quiero creer en esto todos necesitamos
creer en eso pero esto sólo va a correr
ocurrir
si todos empezamos a cuestionarnos el
concepto tradicional de empresas si
todos nos preguntamos qué es una empresa
a qué propósito sirve cómo es
posibilidad y cómo es gobernada
entonces el día de hoy lo que me
gustaría que se llevaron a su casa esa
pregunta
busquen profundamente y pregúntense a
ustedes mismos que es una empresa que
debería ser que me gustaría que fuera
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]